So this is kind of funny, but also sad.
One of the many sham claims that the supporters
of Donald Trump have made about the twenty
twenty election is that dead people voted.
Now, as more and more of these claims are
investigated, more and more of these claims
are being debunked.
I'm going to have a voicemail for you about
dead people voting, but this might come as
a shock to some of you.
In a country of three hundred and thirty one
million people, there are lots of people with
the same name, even people with the same middle
initial.
And when you hear that one hundred and eighteen
year old Joe Smith voted, but Joe Smith died
20 years ago, it might actually be seventy
72 year old Joe Smith that voted from the
same city.
There's this really funny thing.
So when I lived in when I lived in New York
City, I was in a band, one of my band mates.
I'm not going to give his real name.
So people don't go doxxing him, but I'm going
to give you a name that will work.
His first name is Eddie.
Now, Eddie typically would be Edward, but
sometimes Eddie is short for or a nickname
for Edwin.
So my band mates name was Eddie a Jiménez.
OK, let's go.
But let's play that Eddie a Jimenez and he
once looked up.
How many Eddie a humanizes are there in New
York City.
And there's a whole bunch.
OK, but then he said here's what here's more,
a more interesting question.
How many Edwyn a humanizes are there in New
York City?
Edwyn being much less common and there were
eleven.
So even a name like Edwin A. Jiménez, that's
not the actual name.
I'm just modifying it so that people don't
go and try to figure out who this guy is.
There were eleven people with the same middle
initial even Edwyn a human as in New York
City.
So a lot of that is what's going on with these
so-called dead voters.
So the Trump campaign has been alleging dead
voters for a while.
One such example is that Trump's campaign
and Fox News host Tucker Carlson last week
alleged that a Georgia woman named Deborah
Jeane Christianson voted while dead the campaign
and Carlson said it was fraud.
Deborah Jeane Christiansen died last year.
Now, in fact, the vote was legally cast by
a living woman whose name is also Deborah
Jeane Christianson, born in the same year
and the same month, but on a different day
now, CNN eventually interviewed her.
They went to her door.
She was alive.
She was a real person who was alive and voting.
There's another example, which is the case
of Mr. and Mrs. James Blaylock.
Now, Mr. James Blaylock did pass away years
ago.
His wife votes under the name Mrs. James Blaylock.
He or she is alive and well.
Take a look.
He's not a voter.
He didn't vote.
It was you.
It was me.
President of the United States was accusing
you of voter fraud.
A Oh, I know it.
And I knew it wasn't fraud.
Who did you vote for?
You don't have to share that.
I voted for the Democrats, but I think I guess
I voted against the other one.
Really.
So there it is that voters who are actually
alive now, I've also been accused of being
dead before.
Do you guys remember this is it's sort of
an aside.
But years ago there was a documentary, a perfectly
reasonable documentary about gay teens who
were bullied so ferociously in school that
they took their own lives.
And that's a real thing.
That's a very, very sad thing.
But for some reason, we've not been able to
figure out.
I was in the montage in a sort of in memoriam
of a bullied gay teens who died by suicide.
And at the time, this came as a shock to a
lot of people in the audience now, at the
time I was not a teen, I was 27 years old.
At the time, I was not gay and I was not bullied.
And I also wasn't dead, which was important
to clarify.
And I issued a clarification.
So I understand what it's like to be accused
of being dead when you when you were actually
alive.
So this is all completely wacky.
The Trump campaign is making all sorts of
accusations of dead people voting.
Tucker Carlson ended up apologizing for one
false claim about a dead person voting.
Now, even if anecdotally, some of these supposedly
dead voters are either still alive or didn't
vote, it's still worth, I think, doing a more
thorough investigation of this.
And that's what the BBC did.
The BBC looked at the claim that was made
by the Trump campaign or people around Trump,
that 10000 dead, dead people voted in Michigan.
That's that's the top line number 10000 dead
people voted in Michigan.
Now, as a reminder, the margin in Michigan
by which Joe Biden won is about 46000.
So to start with, they're claiming 10000 dead
people voted in Michigan.
Even if those were all Biden votes, it would
not reverse the results.
But BBC started with ten thousand good.
Then the BBC picked 31 names from the list
of dead voters and said, let's research these
31 supposedly dead voters, 11 of the 31 were
alive.
They called them up people.
They said, nope, I'm alive.
No problem, no big deal.
So about one third of the sample of supposedly
dead voters were people who were just alive,
17 of the thirty one supposedly dead voters.
They researched and found no reason to believe
that they were dead.
In other words, for 17 of the 31 people, about
half of the sample Trump hosts are claiming
these people are dead.
They found no death notices, no obituaries.
In many cases.
They found, you know, online profiles of people
who are still alive and, you know, posting
things online.
There was no reason to think 17 of the thirty
one person sample was dead.
And then they found three people of the 31
who actually are dead.
But listen to this.
In two of the three cases where dead people
supposedly voted, it was these situations
of a father and a son with the same name.
And indeed, ballots were requested and returned
under the father's name.
But it was a clerical error.
In other words, the son voted.
It was registered as a vote by the father,
but there was not actually a vote registered
by the son.
So it's not even a double vote like yes, it's
a clerical error, but it was a son voting
under his father's name one time.
No double voting there either.
So, as you can see, taking a random 31 person
sample from the supposedly 10000 dead voters
very, very quickly falls apart.
It's important to do this.
It's important to understand the reality.
Now, let's go to the voicemail which is related
to this.